escribe 6 por 6 por 6 por 6 por 6 por 6
por 6 por 6 en notación exponencial en
notación exponencial entonces cuántas
veces tenemos a seis multiplicado por sí
mismo
aquí tenemos una vez dos veces seis por
dos bueno no tenemos seis por dos
tenemos seis por seis seis que se
multiplica por si mismo dos veces es 6
por 676 mientras 6 por 2 es 12
así es que aquí tenemos 1 2 3 604 6 656
es 66 67 668 6 es así es que estamos
multiplicando a 6 por sí mismo 8 veces
por lo cual para escribir esto en
notación exponencial lo escribimos como
esto es igual a 6 a la 6 a la octava
potencia 6 a la octava potencia lo que
es exactamente igual a 6 por 6 por 6 por
6 por 6 por 6 por 6 por 6
ahora quiero dejar en claro que este
número este número no es
este número no es no es seis por ocho
este número no es 6 por 8 6 por 8 es 48
en cambio 6 a la octava potencia sería 6
por 6 36 y eso multiplicado por 6 que
nos dan 6 por 3 18 6 por 6 36 216 y eso
multiplicado por 6 y por 6 y por 6 en
fin es un número realmente enorme este
de aquí es un número enorme vamos a
ponerlo aquí vamos escribirlo es un
número enorme mientras que este número
de aquí 48 no es un número enorme no es
enorme así es que no te confundas si ves
6 elevado a la octava potencia es 6 x sí
mismo 8 veces no es 6 por 8